"Ставок", я "Сигма", на зв'язку, як прийняв?
Я тоді став, помолився над ним, і все... І він помер…
Кістка зламана, є перелом.
Є кейсевак, а є медевак. Кейсевак - це броньована машина,
яка заїжджає безпосередньо на поле бою
або на точку біля поля бою. І є медевак - це ми.
Неброньований транспорт, більш спеціальний для поранених.
"Ставок", я "Сигма", на зв'язку, як прийняв?
Не завжди кейсевак надає допомогу…
Скоріш за все допомогу надають відразу після поранення,
бо є бойові медики, які безпосередньо на полі бою,
вони воюють і надають першу медичну допомогу.
Часто кейсевак наш без санітарів, там тільки водій.
І він одразу привозить нам, і ми вже тоді надаємо
першу медичну допомогу.
Хто з рукою?
Годинник, обережно. Автомат заберіть.
Сідай у машину.
Спочатку я розпитаю, що сталося, коли, за яких обставин,
бо це мені потрібно, щоб потім надавати доповідь…
А потім я можу спитати і про жінку, і про дітей,
і скільки років, чим займався по життю - про таке, про людське.
Я також віруюча людина.
Навіть деколи можу з пораненими про Бога поговорити.
Був такий один випадок, коли у мене в моїй машині…
Це, сподіваюся, перший і останній побратим,
який загинув у моїй машині. Це не була чиясь вина,
просто ми не встигли. Просто так сталося,
що не встигли його довезти, і він у мене в машині помер.
Перестав дихати. Я робив усе, що міг.
Я пам'ятаю, що я бачу, що він помирає,
оці останні його видихи.
Я тоді став, помолився над ним, і все... І він помер.
Я привіз його на стабпункт недихаючим.
Це, напевно, таке, що найбільше запам'яталося.
Зараз медевак довозить сюди в межах 20 хвилин.
Це більш-менш оптимальний час. Якщо ми поставимо далеко,
в безпечній зоні, збільшиться час, будуть менше довозити хлопців
або їх довозитимуть у важкому стані…
До війни я був серцево-судинним хірургом,
завідуючим відділенням малоінвазивної кардіохірургії
в інституті Амосова.
Військова медицина тут, на стабпункті, це зовсім інше.
Тут нема такої великої хірургії.
Наша задача тут - стабілізувати стан хворого, зупинити кровотечу,
зупинити життєво-загрозливі стани…
Коли йдуть якісь штурмові дії чи з нашої сторони, чи з їхньої сторони,
у нас збільшується кількість поранених.
Будь-який штурм, будь-які дії - у нас роботи збільшується.
Скільки часу турнікет? З 09:30.
Пошукова група йшла і натрапила на мінне поле швидше за все.
Основна маса поранених - це якраз мінно-вибухові травми.
Також артилерійський вогонь, уламки.
Мінно-кульових поранень не так багато.
Кістка заламана. Перелом ось. Давай швиденько.
Фактично в нас тут розкачуватися нема коли, тому що зараз
у будь-який момент може бути надходження нової партії хворих.
Нам треба максимально швидко вивести його
і передати на наступний етап.
У стабільному, хорошому стані.
Тому доводиться концентруватися і працювати швидко.
Звучить трохи цинічно, але звикається…
Можеш кудись посунути (обігрівач), бо воно так у спину жарить,
будь ласка, кудись вбік. Бо вже просто…
У мене таке враження, що там щось загоряється.
Коли я працював у серцево-судинній хірургії у нас так само:
ти ходиш кожен по лезу ножа, так само, як і тут.
Людина або вигорає, або адаптується до цього.
Певно, як і кожен з нас, хто тут, він боїться.
Але немає іншого виходу. Від кейсевака, від мене
залежить життя побратима.
Доводиться.
Коли ти їдеш по пораненого, ти не думаєш про те,
що щось може прилетіти. Коли ти вже виїжджаєш звідти,
від лінії фронту від'їжджаєш далі, ти можеш сісти,
перекурити, і тоді вже тобі находять ці думки,
що ось, ти міг зараз померти.
Але, як я вже казав, я віруюча людина, я знаю, що зі мною Бог.
Я знаю, що мене вдома чекають, мене вдома люблять.
Напевно, це допомагає рухатися вперед, не зламатися тут.
Ні, ні. Дуже маленькі діти. Вони ще про роботу не знають.
У мене троє дітей: 10, 6 і 4 роки.
Вони зараз в Ліоні, у Франції.
(Говоримо) про звичайні дитячі проблеми.
Десь іграшка зламалася, десь у школі щось,
з французькою не виходить - про їхні проблеми...
Я хочу, щоб мої діти були українцями,
щоб вони пишалися, що вони українці.
Ми - держава, незалежна держава і для того, що так було й далі,
я не бачу іншого рішення, яке могло би прийти.